So there's two general hypotheses or
theories about the nature of time.
One of them will call presentism and
present him presentism.
The notion is is that only the present
is real,
the past was real.
The future,
some configuration of the future
universe will be real.
But for now only the president Israel in
contrast,
the posing view is called eternalism
internal wisdom.
We you have the past,
present and future are all equally meal.
So that makes the present just an
arbitrary point in time or an arbitrary
moment in time.
So one way to think about this is now is
to time as here is to space.
So in the same sense that I happen to be
here and some viewers are out at some
other point in space and we're all
comfortable with that notion that other
points in space are equally real and
eternal wisdom.
You have to be comfortable with the
notion that other moments in time or as
equally real as this moment in time,
and this is just an arbitrary moment.
So under that view,
there are other moments or that there's
a continuum of moments in time that are
essentially already laid out within the
universe and that universe in physics
called the block universe.
So under the block universe,
it makes sense to engage in a
conversation about time travel because
there's other moments to go to.
Not that this doesn't speak to the issue
of whether the time travel is actually
applause,
plausible or not,
it's probably not.
But it enables the conversation because
other moments in time exists now under
presentism we can pretty much take the
possibility of time travel off the table
because there's no other moments to go
to.
Only the president is real.
So it doesn't make sense to ask if you
can travel to moments in time in the
past or future that don't exist.
Now there's a clash here between
neuroscience and physics.
So intuitively the time,
time seems to be changing.
We humans experience the flow of time.
Um,
under eternal ISM.
It's where everything is already laid
out.
The flow of time is a deep mystery
because it would seem to be that if all
of moments in time are already laid out
within the block universe,
that the flow of time shouldn't exist or
must be an illusion.
So if the flow of time,
if our subjective sense of the flow of
time is an illusion,
we have this clash between physics and
neuroscience because the dominant theory
in physics is that we live in the block
universe and there's buy nice should be
clear.
There's no consensus,
there's no a hundred percent agreement.
But the standard view in physics is
that,
and this comes large part from
relativity that um,
we live in an eternal student universe.
I'm in the block universe in which the
past,
present future is equally meal.
So this raises the question of whether
we can trust our brain to tell us that
time is flowing.
So I think we need to have a improved
dialogue between physics and
neuroscience here.
So on one hand we have to decide is if
we want to accept that are subjective
sense of the flow of time is an
objective fact about the universe.
We perceive time to be flowing.
Things seem to be changing.
The past seems to be,
um,
vaporizing into,
into the past.
And the future seems to be wide open.
Now,
if it's the case that we live in the
block universe,
that seems to be illusory in a very deep
sense.
So we have to decide if we want to take
our subjective sense of the flow of time
as an objective fact about the universe.
Um,
that must be explained by physics or in
contrast is,
um,
our subjective sense of the flow of
time.
Merely an illusion,
an illusion in the deepest sense of that
word,
because we're perceiving something that
doesn't exist in the physical world,
that physics doesn't need to explain
because it doesn't exist.
And thus,
neuroscience needs to address where the
solution comes from and the solution is
presumably tightly,
um,
coupled with the problem of
consciousness.
Mm.